manche bakterien sind echte co2 fresser
forschungsteams tüfteln an einer
neuartigen braut technologie die aus dem
klima gefährlichen kohlendioxid einen
rohstoffmacht ethanol nämlich mit dem
autos angetrieben werden könnten ist das
die rettung für unser klima klicks und
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden dem
technologie magazin des emmett dem
massachusetts institute of technology
und am ende gibt es ein exemplar für
euch kostenlos schon vor 15 jahren
hatten fachleute aus belgien eine super
spannende entdeckung gemacht sie hatten
bis dahin unbekannte bakterien
aufgespürt die einer kraftstoff fabriken
denn das bakterium clostridium auto
ethanol genom ernährt sich von
kohlenmonoxid und kohlendioxid und
stellt dabei ethanol er zuschauer zu
sein denn mit ethanol können nicht nur
autos angetrieben werden durch chemische
umwandlung kann das ethanol auch sprit
hergestellt werden mit dem flugzeuge
fliegen das us-unternehmen landtag hat
sich diese mikroben zu nutze gemacht
dafür am fachleute eine neue braut
technologie entwickelt und aus dem
klimaschädlichen co2 wird wertvolles
ethanol das start-up produziert mit
hilfe der bakterien bis zu 40.000 tonnen
davon pro jahr dafür werden die abgase
aus der benachbarten fabrik genutzt
einem stahlwerk auch in belgien
südafrika und kalifornien sind weitere
standorte geplant die in kooperation mit
verschiedenen anderen industrien an den
start gehen könnten beispielsweise mit
einer firma die metall verarbeitet oder
aber einem unternehmen das müsse weiter
verarbeitet denn deren abfälle können in
biomasse kraftwerken verbrannt werden
der abgasstrom daraus ist leckeres
futter für die bakterien getestet wird
derzeit ob möglicherweise auch die
entweichenden gaza einer mülldeponie
genutzt werden können um die mikroben zu
ernähren und somit kraftstoff zu
erzeugen dazu der landtag mitarbeiter
michael köpke angetrieben hat uns dass
die biokraftstoffproduktion dringend
benötigte anbauflächen für lebensmittel
wegnimmt und den hunger in der welt
verschlimmert heißt also mithilfe der
bakterien und der braut technologie
und ethanol hergestellt ohne dass es
dafür anbauflächen braucht die bakterien
dieser firma sind besonders robust und
es braucht keinen katalysator also einen
chemischen stoff der zwischengeschaltet
ist lanza tag füttert seine bakterien
mit kohlenmonoxid kohlendioxid und
energiereichen wasserstoff alles
zusammen wird auch als synthesegas
bezeichnen auch in deutschland setzt man
auf diese braut technologie so zum
beispiel das unternehmen im honig in
nordrhein westfalen ist eine
versuchsanlage im aufbau in der zwei
bakterien spezies eingesetzt werden
clostridium auto ethanol genom und kos
tritium kluy wäre der große plan ist das
ganze jetzt auch wirtschaftlich zu
machen dazu der wissenschaftler
vollkommen aus frankfurt
die ethanolherstellung aus synthesegas
ist bis dato nicht kompetitiv mit der
bioethanolherstellung als zucker also
nicht wettbewerbsfähig im besten fall
sollen aus dem kohlendioxid neben
ethanol zeitnah auch noch weitere
produkte entstehen und zwar werthaltige
spezialchemikalien und tatsächlich sind
die bakterien dazu in der lage
es kommt nur darauf an mit welchen
mikroben sie in einer gemeinschaft leben
das ist entscheidend dafür welche stoffe
diese bakterien herstellen
die mikroben müssen dafür also nicht
einmal gen technisch optimiert werden
bis diese verfahren auch wirklich
kommerziell nutzbar sind wird es nach
ansicht von fachleuten wohl noch einige
jahre dauern dazu thomas haas von evonik
wir würden zunächst anlagen dort
errichten wo produkte leicht zugänglich
ist aber der abgasstrom keinen
sauerstoff enthält das wären
biogasanlagen und bioethanolanlagen eine
riesige herausforderung hat das ganze
aber die bakterien brauchen für diesen
prozess wasserstoff und dieser ist nur
sehr energieaufwendig herzustellen und
zwar mit strom der elektrolyse ein
ansatz ist es die energie dafür aus
erneuerbaren energien zu beziehen
zudem hält die kohlendioxid brauereien
eine zweite herausforderung bereit das
gas das die bakterien füttern darf zum
einen nicht zu viel sauerstoff enthalten
und zum anderen darf es sich auch nicht
um reines kohlendioxid
doch genau das kommt eben aus unseren
autos den kraftwerken und schornstein
das müsste also erst in kohlenmonoxid
umgewandelt werden unter einsatz von
energie die schlote also die an den
brauch gäste angehängt werden können
müssen bestimmte voraussetzungen
erfüllen und der schornstein eines
kohlekraftwerkes scheidet aus zu viel
sauerstoff und zu wenig kohlenmonoxid
als kleiner hoffnungsschimmer
noch eine bestimmte mikrobe namens
accedo bakterium rudi sie ist zwar
sauerstoff empfindlich frist dafür aber
reines kohlendioxid und wasserstoff
braucht also kein kohlenmonoxid so
könnte man in zement verbringen die
chemie anlagen und kraftwerken das
kohlendioxyd abtrennen in tanks pressen
und dieses dann an genau dieses
bakterium verfüttern ein krasser plan
denn dzeko bakterium wo die ist in der
lage methanol und ameisensäure
herzustellen dabei handelt es sich um
wichtige basis chemikalien doch bisher
gibt es erst eine kleinere
versuchsanlage mit aceton bakterium
moody heißt also dass die kohlendioxid
brauerei bislang noch nicht die lösung
aller klimaprobleme ist dafür müsste es
erst mal noch einen großen durchbruch
bei der künstlichen photosynthese geben
also dem nachbau der pflanzlichen
energiegewinnung im labor
dann könnte die sonne die arbeit über
den die nun in den braukessel der
energiereiche wasserstoff übernimmt also
das träge kohlendioxid im stoffwechsel
der bakterien zu aktivieren doch bisher
ist der künstlichen nachbau der
photosynthese nur unvollständig und
nicht effizient genug für industrielle
prozesse
denn sie ist einfach sehr komplex zwei
enzyme sind bei der photosynthese
beteiligt so viel ist bekannt dazu der
deutsche wissenschaftler mark nowaczyk
sie bestehen aus 10.000 bis 100.000 atom
und sind unwahrscheinlich raffiniert
gebaut normaler enzyme haben nur einige
tausend atome wir haben sie immer noch
nicht zur gänze entschlüsseln auch der
einsatz von organismen die sowieso
photosynthese betreiben läuft bisher im
großen stil noch nicht wirklich optimal
die kosten sind hoch aber die ausbeute
klein allerdings hoffen die fachleute
dass die verschmelzung von bio und
nanotechnologie zeitnah zu einem
durchbruch führen könnte denn mit hilfe
der nanotechnologie könnten die
photosynthetischen mikroorganismen auf
zwei oder drei dimensionalen oberflächen
gedruckt werden vergleichbar wie bei
einem halbleiter chip oder einer
solarzelle
so könnten die lebewesen so angeordnet
werden dass sie optimal dem licht
ausgesetzt sind us-forschern ist
dahingehend ein erster schritt gelungen
sie haben tatsächlich verschiedene
bakterien an nanoskalige
halbleitermaterial strukturen gebunden
diese nano bio hybride konnten unter
anderem biologisch abbaubaren kunststoff
kraftstoff und
von jan aus kohlendioxid und licht
erzeugen solche lebenden name strukturen
könnten in der zukunft dann auf einem
chip angebracht werden solarkollektoren
auf dem dach könnten dann sogar den
sprit für das eigene auto liefern
spannende zukunftsperspektiven und noch
mehr davon gibt es bei technology review
in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von
technology review ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für klicks um
zuschauer und zuschauerinnen gibt es
jetzt eine ausgabe gratis klickt dafür
einfach auf diesen link her oder unten
in der video beschreibung es lohnt sich
der kanadische review ist mega
interessant und hier geht es zu einem
weiteren video das wir mit der redaktion
gemacht haben krank durch 5g studien
zeigen beunruhigende ergebnisse also
anklicken anschauen und klicks zum
tanzen fiction abonnieren bis dann